so 500 people I've spent the last 45
minutes looking for deals calculating
the return on investment only this day
agents and we've been learning a skill
which is how to package and then sell
present the deal so what we're going to
do now is I'm gonna give people an
opportunity to come up onto the stage
and present their deal to everybody and
the winning team is gonna get some money
now this really this isn't a lot of
money this is just a few hundred pounds
but this is just a little incentive
because ultimately when you can do this
skill when you know that a package a
deal and you know to pass it on to an
investor you're not going to get 300
pounds you're gonna get like three
thousand pounds per deal so I'm trying
to give them the skills to be able to do
that because anyone can package a deal
and pass it on to a property investor if
they've got the right knowledge and the
right skills and the right training and
then you can use that money to say but
put tools deposits so it's a really good
strategy everyone seems to have done
really well so let's see what happens I
still need I still need a good deal man
I mean what's going on here I don't
what's your return on investment is it
good
did you guys know each other already
you're all strangers in that case come
and take the stage all away from Kent
okay cool how did you how did you find
the whole exercise not what happened we
need to go home I want to go home but
you still mention get a deal
yeah what's the return on investment
twenty four point five nine twenty four
point five nine and what do you do for a
living right now I'm a teacher you're a
teacher
yeah why here and um I just want to kind
of like not work anymore okay I work and
I work two jobs well currently free jobs
and I just want a little bit more time
and I don't want to ask you super
personal question but sort of income was
roughly I what sort of income and you
want per month and teaching at the
moment I do three days a week so I don't
even get enough to get taxed at the
moment and then I do waitress in and
then I do other bits on the side as well
alright there's people that work
extremely hard for like fifteen hundred
pound a month folks many people even
industry like that's quite standard
work really hard 1,500 pound a month
this is what I say don't work really
hard work really smart if your deals as
good as it sounds it might be these kind
of deals you can sell them for two
thousand pound like that and then take
the rest of the month off that's why
we're here so confidence coming on stage
I'm impressed
next whistle oh yeah you're a hand grant
better
how about your way from I'm from Luton
cool and like what did you learn in this
whole exercise I learned that you really
have to get in touch with the agents and
find properties because if you don't do
that no one will so that's the main
reason yeah yeah I saw and that's what
all of our training programs that we run
is the practical rather than just the
theory you can sit at home and read
books and watch TV all day you'll never
get rich never get rich you'll get rich
by doing stuff like this put yourself in
the right environment right place right
time pick up the phone make it happen so
awesome because for me this is the first
time so I never call anyone so that's
why you Joe is the big like improvement
so that's why I'm here
dude how many of you made the phone call
to an agent for the very first time like
half the room all right
dan dan what do you do for a living
project manage it but I should work for
a property company Wow
cool so how did you find this this
exercise working in a property company
good actually interesting yeah I've
actually got a few properties of my own
already I'm up to four but I'm not
getting the sort of returns that I've
seen you get and Dan already property
property construction got four
properties already but still humble
enough to come to a program to want to
learn and do more great good for you
good for you good for you and and
insect-like me last six months I've
spent I've spent quarter of a million
pounds on my own education me going on
training programs because you know you
always learn more have you learned a lot
today
yes been good really good okay are you
ready to give me the postcode in a
moment yeah I won't do it I'll pass this
over to Holly because she's won I found
it all right
okay so Holly get the postcode ready
we're gonna find this and because you've
all been on stage so long hopefully the
deals that sticking to be decent
all right go ahead what's the postcode
BD 4 BB 4 9 RX 9 RX o BD 4 that sounds
like Bradford Brad
did anyone already see this house you
guys found the house so let me ask you a
question when you guys found the exact
same house as these guys why are they on
stage and not you if I'm the same house
energy in real life doing this business
there's going to be deal sources out
there the deals that they find all with
the same deals or worse than your deals
and they'll be making way more money why
because they tell the world that they're
a property investor why because they had
the energy put himself on stage okay Tom
Street firstly folks what's the
condition like at this house looks
decent for a bite tonight does it look
like a decent little house yes or no
looks okay all right it says that the
achievable rents 400 did you speak to
the agent
yes I spoke to the agent and they said I
said I don't want to offend anybody but
I'm an investor and I'm looking for
something a little cheaper with day
would it be well would it be worth
booking a viewing for foot if I'm
looking at kind of spending forty four K
they said yes I spoke about the rental
value and they said even though it's on
four hundred there they is very likely
that I'd get four thirty I then looked
at other properties around the area and
they like some of them two bedroom
houses were going for about six hundred
so four thirty
where did you look where did you look
within a mile radius of the postcode on
Rightmove what I think it was open Rin
all right well should we should we see
folks what the radius there was a little
one-bedroom flat so we're gonna do like
four like it's okay so we're gonna we're
gonna now find out that said she said
that she could only offer about forty
four yes and they said book of viewing
on it now listen if if they'd have said
not like when Brian said oh listen it's
on for fifty but I'm probably gonna be
offering less they were like no this is
a steal because the tenants are in there
I mean it'd be awkward in the viewings
that's why it's so cheap so Ryan knows
now this upfront when you say hey could
you would they accept
before and they say you know what can't
say for sure be worth of Ewing then you
go view they can't be offended that
you've roughly 44 yeah okay so we're
gonna look and we're gonna be looking
for like for like here so that you can
see this is in a small little area and
we're looking for a to bad like this mid
terraced so there's quite a lot of flats
but we need to like for like to bid
terrorists 550 and all you're getting
this is a piece of land as well now you
caught even the pit they're not even
marketing me well but that's gone that's
let let of 550 let's see this one to bed
terrorists say an area five for five
Wow so they're saying the rents how much
400 but actually it's probably a little
conservative listen look at this one too
bad five to five now your house is on
450 grams
it says achievable weight of 400 but for
market research it looks like probably
he might be able to get how much do you
guys reckon maybe even five what did you
work out the return on investment based
on the rent being the rent being at
minimum kind of 4:30 I wanted to do not
minimum condom you gave me very specific
or a whopping so you worked out on 4:30
do you think that's realistic guys yes
or no so if you get suppose didn't know
you don't think you get that I'm more
right I thought you said nor in a
northern accent and she said more so so
you probably get more so 4:30 is a
conservative rent what did you work out
pass the mic on to my loot and friend
what did you work out the the buying the
house for 44 44 cuz the agent okay which
is that is that fair to assume yes or no
so if you bought the house for 44 grand
based on what the agent said you rent
out for 4:30 which we know you will be
able to do that's gonna give you over
every turn investment of how much 261
pounds sorry the return on investment oh
no don't be twenty four point six twenty
four point six do you think twenty four
point six will be a realistic return
investment yes or no now personally I
think it might be more but you've got to
be negative when it comes to buying
houses you've got to look at worst case
you've got to be conservative
I honestly believe we have a program
called deal selling mastery where we
teach you how to sell deals on the deal
of selling mastery we'd sell that on the
spot in front of you for two thousand
pound so so Holley your work as a
teacher and a waitress could be replaced
by finding one deal at that amount if
you find it 45 minutes so so listen up I
am gonna make you guys an offer okay
you've got you've got a few options now
what you can do because I am quite I
like this house
I like this house and we just have a
quick I mean geez look into it look in
2004 it was bought for 42 250 now 15
years later 44 like that's bottomed out
so bad you couldn't build that for 44
grand there's only one way that's going
and it's going which way it's gonna give
me a nice cash flow I like this house
here's my offer okay got three options
option number one is I will give you
guys 100 pounds each in cash on the spot
right now and then the deals mine option
number two you guys can club together
and you can buy the deal on joint
venture money or whatever you want to do
option number three is you can wait
until tomorrow where we learn normally
down deals well at least options and do
your packaging and stuff and you can try
and be creative and package the deal
instead of someone else or you can try
and do a lease option on it or something
like that so those are your three
options now of course in any business
decision like this there's a group of
you you're gonna have to have like a
discussion a business meeting about this
fair enough yes so I'm going to give you
a chance to have a business meeting
about this so you're going to have 20
seconds
so because listen listen listen how many
of you realize that in business
sometimes you need to make fast
decisions yes or no yes or no they
always are business people don't know
about this over the weekend I'll speak
to more I'll speak to my lawyer I can
sort my dog like come on so 20 seconds
those are three options twenty seconds
starts now
okay pastor Pastor Mike to Haleh
mastermind to Holly Holly
all right firstly before you tell us
what you decided or before you make your
decision of your heart for your team
what would you do if you were these guys
what jeanikins mission do wait till
tomorrow but what could I lose you know
all right
drum roll please drum roll please Holly
what are you going to do tell us right
now and you're gonna take money they're
gonna take a boner
[Applause]
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 there you go
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]